the deranged hellscape that is the
modern american right wing just
continues to get worse i want to look at
a couple of data points for you guys
last night quite literally as vladimir
putin and russia started bombing in
ukraine sending missiles to kiev and
kharkiv and all over the country quite
literally
donald trump again praised vladimir
putin this time at a very strange speech
he gave at his own mar-a-lago resort now
yesterday i brought you the clip of
donald trump saying um on this podcast
hosted by buck sexton and another guy
trump saying that putin was savvy
and smart and genius for what he did to
ukraine and some people said david that
was taken out of context
well trump doubled down on it again
here is donald trump at a mar-a-lago
event last night saying putin is smart
he's taken a country over for two
dollars worth of sanctions i'd say
that's pretty smart take a look at this
trump said he's smart i mean he's taken
over a country
for two dollars worth of sanctions i'd
say that's pretty smart trump is saying
yeah
it is smart it is smart trump's actually
responding to the people who said wow to
buck sexton trump said how smart putin
is that's crazy and trump is going it is
smart what putin's doing is smart now i
understand in this clip he's not saying
i support it but he's clearly enamored
with the authoritarian nature of putin
as we've known for years
he's taking over a country
really a vast
vast
location a great piece of land with a
lot of people it's just great real
estate that putin's getting for two
bucks of sanctions
this would have never happened ever in a
million years would have never happened
and i know him very well i know probably
almost as well as i know anybody in this
room other than doctor
well if trump really has the
relationship with putin that he that he
claims to have and if this really would
never have happened uh if trump was
currently in power
why doesn't trump just call putin and
say hey it's time to lay off ukraine i
mean if trump wants us to believe that
putin respects trump
trump wants us to believe that putin
listens to trump
and that trump has power over over putin
well if you don't like what he's doing
just call him and say hey it's time to
lay off and of course the answer is
either because trump doesn't have that
relationship with putin or because he
likes what vladimir putin is doing now
he's certainly impressed with it i don't
think trump cares at all about ukraine
i think trump is probably indifferent
about putin invading ukraine trump
doesn't care about ukrainians or ukraine
uh but he can't just say i love the
invasion instead he has to just talk
about how smart vladimir vladimir putin
is
imagine for a second by the way
if trump
was president when this was going on it
would be like another rehash of when
trump met with putin in helsinki and
asked him about the hacking where he was
like oh putin denied it very strongly i
just spoke to putin and he says the
invasion is fine i asked him uh did you
do anything wrong and he said sir no
everything we're doing in ukraine is
okay and he said it very strongly it was
a very true putin was very strong on it
so i believe him the invasion's fine
that's what would be going on
and uh if you think this is bonkers just
wait until we look at these next series
of clips
one of our sponsors is splendid spoon
now if you're like me i love planning my
meals out for the week but sometimes i
just run out of time to plan them for
every single day and splendid spoon
makes that whole process a lot easier
they deliver fresh delicious plant-based
meals right to your door
ready to eat no cooking no cleaning
dishes saves you a lot of time you can
choose from over 50 hot and cold meal
options there's smoothies grain and
noodle bowls soups i'm a big soup guy
many of you know that i also really
liked the vegan meatballs with marinara
noodles delicious
both eye and splendid spoon believe
eating more plant-based is a great tool
for feeling good
for helping the environment the list
goes on i'm not vegan you all know that
i think but splendid spoon is really
great to just help me maximize the
proportion of plants in my diet splendid
spoon takes all of the work out of tasty
healthy plant-based meals and you'll
save 35 dollars when you go to
splendidspoon.com
pacman the link is down below